stay for example we want to find out
what the angular speed is for let's just
say it's a wheel that's turning at 4
revolutions per minute okay so just a
wheel that's rotating at 4 revolutions
per minute so what you do is you start
off with four revolutions per one minute
okay and what you want to do is you want
to convert into that angular speed so
that's the angle per unit time so what
we're going to do is we're going to
multiply by two pi radians per one
revolution so if you remember unit
circle two pi radians is what one
revolution is equivalent to and so your
revolutions cancel and now you have
radians per minute if you multiply the
numerators and denominators you get
eight pi radians per minute so that's
your angle per unit time your angle
angular speed now if you want to find
your linear speed say this wheel that
we're discussing let's just say it has a
three foot diameter so say this is three
feet and if you remember that
circumference equals pi times diameter
so circumference the distance all the
way around so the circumference is going
to be 3 pi feet for every one revolution
so if you go once around that distance
is three PI feet for every one turn
where every one rotation so if we want
to convert from four revolutions per
minute to the linear speed linear is
like the length per unit time we've got
four revs for one minute and we're going
to multiply by for every one revolution
you're going to be travelling 3 pi feet
so 3pi feet so you can see that the
revolutions cancel
and you end up with feet per minute so
let's just multiply across that's 12 pi
feet per one minute okay so that's
angular speed and linear speed so the
next problem I want to show you this
one's a little bit more complicated some
students have trouble with this but
again just think about converting from
the unit's that you don't want into the
unit's that you do want so let's take a
look at that problem so what we're gonna
do in this one real analyze a vehicle
that's traveling at 60 miles per hour
okay some type of a vehicle is traveling
at 60 miles per hour and let's just say
that the tires on this vehicle let's
just say that they're 1.5 feet okay
that's the diameter which means that the
circumference is 1.5 pi feet per one Rev
and let's say we want to convert to
revolutions per minute so we're starting
with 60 miles per hour the vehicles
traveling we're going to convert miles
into feet
so one mile for every 5,280 feet so see
how the miles cancel numerator and
denominator you end up with feet per
hour now the feet
we know there's 1.5 PI feet per
revolution
so let's convert 1.5 PI feet per 1 Rev
so the feet cancel see numerator
denominator cancel now we have
revolutions per hour we want to convert
that into revolutions per minute
okay so right now we've got hours so
let's see here we've got for every 1
hour there are 60 minutes so you can see
the hours are cancelling with the hours
denominator and numerator and we're
going to end up with the unit's we do
want which are revolutions per minute
your revolutions per minute
so all you have to do is multiply across
all the numerators all the denominators
and divide so we'll just do that real
quick on the calculator so you have that
if you want to compare 60 times 5,280
okay divided by in parenthesis 1.5 pi
times 60 so we get one thousand one
hundred and twenty point five so one
thousand one hundred and twenty point
five revolutions per minute so these are
a couple examples for finding linear
speed angular speed just think of it as
a unit conversion problem and that'll
make it simple to solve so check out
some of my other videos if you have
other questions regarding problems
you're having with your math and if you
need to review this prop of this video
again to understand these problems a bit
better
see you in the next video